foreign
it was meant to be the biggest
solidarity demonstration since the coup
the stadium may not be full but Ninja's
cool leaders seized the moment hoping to
capitalize on anti-front sentiments here
our Liberation is never complete until
the last French soldier leaves our soil
[Applause]
we bring you the message of the head of
state that we will defeat traitors will
defeat and Destroy them you should never
let down your guard
on July 26th dozens of presidential
Guard soldiers entrusted with protecting
the president overthrew Muhammad basil
they've been holding him since then
the dominant theme of Saturday Israeli
is to get the French out but there are
also anti-equal sentiments
has lost credibility
knows we aren't scared of its threats it
doesn't support no help its member
states they blockaded us and cut off
electricity to Niger after a month-long
stand up Echoes appetite for an armed
invasion of Niger seemed to be waning
the biggest worry for the cool leaders
here is the impact of sanctions and the
loss of external Aid and this has become
more pressing now that water closures
have cut off supplies
but the military High command was also
quick to warn supporters not to attack
the French Embassy because that could be
a protect to attack Niger
the Gathering was built as a million-man
demonstration of loyalty despite
misgivings niger's military Junta has
lasted a month and remains defiant the
cool leaders say they are open to
dialogue but the sticking points remain
their proposed three-year transition
back to democracy and the fate of the
post-president Mohammed bazoom Ahmed
Idris al-jazeera nyame
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera